Watching a movie with friends and loved ones
can enrich the experience for everyone.
But, as with all things, there are exceptions.
Trust us, you won't want someone sitting next
to you while any of these movies are on.
Her is a film about a lonely dude who buys
a sophisticated operating system that contains
a charming artificial intelligence, and then
promptly falls in love with her.
It's quite literally about a man who falls
in love with a screen.
In that way, there's something absolutely
perfect about watching it by yourself, particularly
if you're feeling a tad lonely, just for the
sheer satirical value of it all.
Beyond that, though, there's something more
to Her that begs to be considered in a solitary,
quiet way.
Some people see the film as more of a comedy
mocking our relationship to technology.
Others, meanwhile, see it as a very sincere
study of our relationship to tech, and to
each other.
Either way, it's a fascinating film full of
questions you'd rather not have a friend asking
aloud in your ear while you watch.
Alex Garland's gorgeous yet disturbing sci-fi
masterpiece was one of the most underseen
but fascinating films of 2018, and now that
it's available to watch at home, you're in
a prime position to watch it in the dark,
by yourself, absorbing every little detail
of the Shimmer and the weird way it seeps
into the brains of the film's characters.
Annihilation is a film rich in visual and
thematic textures.
It's a treatise on trauma and guilt, an exploration
of what it means to be an individual, and
a glimpse at what happens when we finally
get the transformation we so desperately seek.
It's also a film that leaves the answers to
the questions it ponders somewhat ambiguous,
and while it can be fun to discuss theories
with people the moment the movie is over,
Annihilation is a story that rewards silent
contemplation.
It's a film that begs you not only to watch
it intently, but to sit with it in silence
for a while after the credits have rolled.
With the right audience, the original Twin
Peaks series can be a blast to watch in a
group.
It's quirky, it's funny, it's scary without
being overwhelming, and it's full of fun little
character details and quotes you can all talk
about later.
"Entering the town of Twin Peaks.
It's 5 miles south of the Canadian border,
12 miles west of the state line.
I've never seen so many trees in my life."
Fire Walk With Me, the prequel film that followed
the original show's cancellation, is a different
beast.
Directed by co-creator David Lynch without
his Twin Peaks creative partner Mark Frost,
Fire Walk With Me abandons many of the more
comedic and lighthearted elements of the series
in favor of the bleak, brutal, absolutely
nightmarish story of the last week of Laura
Palmer's life.
It's often a hard film to watch, and it expands
the Peaks mythology in ways that are often
hard to grasp upon first viewing, even with
that feature-length collection of deleted
scenes to expand the series' lore.
Watching it with a raucous crowd of Twin Peaks
fans might not work, so, instead, watch it
quietly and absorb the many mysteries of a
place both wonderful and strange.
Even at their zaniest, the films of the Coen
brothers are all marked by the duo's detail-oriented
and deeply intellectual signature style.
That makes nearly all of them challenging
in some way, but Barton Fink might be their
most cerebral effort ever.
The surreal story of a gifted playwright who
heads out to Hollywood in an attempt to bring
a degree of seriousness and meaning to motion
pictures, the film is an existential examination
of creative self-seriousness, which the film
itself both embraces and pokes fun at.
"Strange as it may seem, Charlie, I guess
I write about people like you: the average
working stiff, the common man."
"Well, ain't that a kick in the head."
The film's themes, dialogue, and visual symbolism
all mirror the process of Fink's own confidence
and intellectual prowess going up in flames,
and what a glorious fire it is!
Watching the film alone both enhances the
sense of isolation you share with Fink as
a viewer, and underlines the cerebral loneliness
at play.
Like the films of The Coen brothers, the films
of Paul Thomas Anderson are often overwhelmingly
cerebral, rich with a meaning that isn't always
obvious but is always compelling enough to
make a careful viewer lean forward and take
notice.
The Master, perhaps more than any of his other
work, deliberately grabs at viewers' attention
with a tale about a charismatic leader, played
by the late Philip Seymour Hoffman, and the
curious convert who joins his cause.
"You shouldn't work in your condition."
"No, I can work."
"You're aberrated."
"No, I'm not."
"Know what that means?"
"No."
Comparisons to L. Ron Hubbard and Scientology
are obvious on the surface, but whatever The
Master is searching for in its own tense,
fascinating way runs much deeper than a thinly
veiled allegory for a real life belief system.
In Anderson's hands, the film becomes a meditation
on manhood, faith, self-destruction, longing,
fear, and raw human endurance.
These are heavy things in a heavy movie, and
they're really worth sitting with alone, particularly
if the people you typically share your couch
with are the type to ask too many questions
the film itself isn't willing to answer.
"If we meet again in the next life, you will
be my sworn enemy, and I will show you no
mercy."